what's good everyone Michael coming to
you from CES 2018 and we're at retro
bits booth and we're going to take you
on a tour where what's old is new first
thing that's new at CES is the super
retro trio plus now this is a console
that plays three different types of
games the SNES NES and Sega Genesis it
takes the original carts and then sends
them out through HDMI and 720p now
slates are released by the end of
January for 80 bucks in the package you
get the console and you get two
controllers as well the super retro trio
plus also has a regional switch so you
can play NTSC and PAL cartridges takes
it all in addition to releasing a
console that plays all kinds of
old-school games retro fit is also
making cartridges of those old games
they'll bring them back Holy Diver from
the NES days it's coming out in May of
this year and there will be a
collector's edition for 60 bucks or as a
standard ition will be 35 bucks
now the collector's edition does come
with some cool stuff like a pin set a
bunch of stickers and a special edition
box retro bit is also bringing back our
type 3 and super r-type with our tech
returns it's also due for release in May
of this year there will be a standard
edition for 40 bucks and a collector's
edition for 60 with the collector's
edition you get pins stickers and a
special edition box as well a Joe and
Mac collector's edition is also due out
in May and it comes in a blue cartridge
[Music]
retrofit is also bringing out something
that looks a lot like the Gameboy the go
retro portable comes with pre-loaded
games you'll see classics from companies
like Capcom and data East this is due
out in September of this year and it'll
go for 35 bucks
this little handheld charges through
microUSB and on a full charge it lasts
up to 10 hours
it features an LCD screen and has a 3.5
millimeter audio jack retro bit is also
bringing back some old sega controllers
as you can see here there's a bluetooth
wireless version of the old Genesis
controller there's a wired of USB
version as well
retro bit also didn't forget about the
Dreamcast there will be a wireless and
wired version of the Dreamcast
controllers and don't forget about the
Sega Saturn they will also have wired
and wireless versions so that's
everything new that retro bid is showing
off at CES 2018 stick to GameSpot for
more coverage of the event thanks for
watching
[Music]